most people rent their Apartments these
days or their houses most people work at
jobs where they don't have equity in it
only 15 percent of humans actually own
stocks which would be equity in
companies by and large we're becoming a
nation or a world of renters when we
started over the last century finally
becoming owners after years of serfdom
that is my mission is I want more human
beings to have their little plot of land
figuratively or physically because I
think that that changes the way we look
at the world then we start to become
stewards of it then we start becoming
stewards of our country you don't burn
down the building that you own right you
fix it you renovate it you build on it